Speaker 1: Today we have two stories about Russian
prisons, quite frankly. A number of you wrote to
me yesterday and you sent me an article about a
teacher being imprisoned for political speech in
Russia and said, David, is this the woman who
called in to your show a few months ago? Now,
I've already looked. I don't believe it is the
same woman unless the woman who called in was
deliberately giving wrong information about
where she teaches and different things. But
it is a very cautionary tale about what exactly
was said by our caller and what she feared because
of her political views. So let me reset it for
you. Article says Russian Teacher Sentenced
For Telling Students About War Crimes in
Ukraine. This article is about Irina again,
who received a five year suspended sentence and
has been barred from working in state schools. And
if you read the article, it says this is a school
teacher in a provincial, provincial Russian city.
She got a suspended sentence because she spoke
out against the Kremlin's invasion of Ukraine
and she was found guilty of discrediting the
Russian armed forces. There is a new law that bans
criticism of the war in Ukraine and she got a five
year suspended sentence and is barred from working
in state schools for three years. The court also
found that she disseminated false information by
telling students about the siege of Mariupol and
Russian airstrikes killing children in Ukraine.
She was slapped with charges in March. So this was
actually this predates our caller. But remember
the caller we had who called in under a pseudonym
for exactly these types of fears. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Taking my question.
Speaker 1: So before you go,
you're calling from Russia?
Speaker 2: Yeah, from Moscow.
Speaker 1: And so what is the would you say
the general sentiment there is that people
like the invasion of Ukraine or people
are against the invasion of Ukraine?
Speaker 2: I have to say that I will have a
certain Moscow liberal bias because that's
the area where I was raised and my family has
always been critical of the government. There is
not a single person in my immediate circles that
are fans of this government. Okay. But I will say
that's just from my own personal experience,
just looking at cars or driving or parking
anywhere. I don't see a single Z sign. There
is no single, I would say, personal initiative
to install anything that is commemorative to this
war. All I've seen is state council local efforts,
which are sponsored from the state, from the
federal budget to try and convince people to
engage in such practices and some type of coercion
that's happening, for example, in kindergartens.
Oftentimes, parents discover that the school trip
or the kindergarten trip they send their children
to was actually a sort of patriotic event because
they then later find pictures of the children
posed in the letter Z on social media.
Speaker 1: That's the patriotic education
Trump keeps talking about. Now, listen,
do you feel safe expressing your views,
antagonistic to the government?
Speaker 2: On here he has over at my university.
I've already sort of spoken myself into
15 years of prison, if anybody would like,
deep, deep anywhere around me. So this is just a
weird spaces that I know that if anybody looked
at me or what I've been writing, what I've been
saying, it is quite possible that I will face
some sort of fine or maybe even jail time.
After all, our person was arrested yesterday
for walking out with a printout of Russian
constitution on the streets and couldn't walk.
Speaker 1: So obviously not the same person. Our
caller called in May and we know that Iran again
was already under prosecution starting
in March. So not the same caller. But
these are not unfounded fears. And thankfully,
Irina again has only received a suspended sentence
and can no longer teach in state schools and will
not be imprisoned. But these are real concerns,
and this is what so many right wingers are
impressed with, quite frankly. This is the type
of they they find Putin to be incredibly strong.
It's sort of like when Duterte is strong because
he encourages the killing of drug dealers. It is
a crazy world out there. And these authoritarians
are actually gaining support around
the world, including from Americans
in the United States, in the
American right wing. Very scary stuff